what is happening reject nation its Greg
Alba camp and Shawn over here so we're
gonna watch the tour at bad trailer
Kings went to the Golden Circle John
enough chitchat
shut up I got a dang game within the
Kings maintains sharply landed a short
lead um maybe you've heard of us you're
wrong yeah great marks the beginning of
a new age
[Music]
a little bit of a save the world
situationally writing the statement your
marital cousins will be working samos
[Music]
yeah hi
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
very American air you [ __ ] yeah hey hey
I got a bad guy or something maybe I
just hope it's not Jeff Bridges yeah I
don't think so
we've been dividing up the reactions in
the reviews I mean we've talked plenty
about Kings with in previous reactions
so we can just keep this all in one
video today I think I look really
awesome everything's really amped up as
you'd expect for a Kingsman sequel to be
even more superhero like than he was in
the prior one every one of the action
sequences are I like the inclusion of
the Statesmen we didn't really elaborate
that on the previous trailers but in
this one you get more of the statesman
here and I think it's cool to be
exploring because the first one is very
much a British film and you know Matthew
Vaughn directing it too and it takes
place in the UK making like the cowboy
action side is pretty cool for Matthew
Vaughn to be taking on your bow you like
cowboy action look really cool in this
trailer well they're like expanding the
world and I like that each iteration of
the Kingsmen is sort of tied into you
know his country's ideal badass you know
yeah so you got like chains mono once I
get Cowboys on the other side and I'm
like this almost like like a really
amped up John wick to me in the way that
it's like unfolding its world
yeah Channing Tatum and I'm glad we got
actually here talking this one and he's
having such a fun time and I feel like
Colin Firth is probably going to get
more screen time than the previous
trailers lead led us to believe that
you'll probably show up a little bit
later in the film but based off how
they're billing him in this and that
he's featured a little more on the true
and imagine a more screen time at this
one that I previously thought he might
have there Gandalf and again you know
let me know right OHS we're back and
Jeff Bridges and just do it is annoying
southern action that he always does it
but I just think it's cool if for the
American side they're taking they're
making them like the southern American
side but they're being in badass van
it's now boys there's still cowboys but
in a modern-day world with modern day
technology ahead I'm interested to see
how this world builds physics now cuz
there's some stuff that looks even
bigger like the first movie is big and
it's
unless set pieces are pretty crazy yeah
but you know like seeing stuff in this
like that lasso that that must have a
bunch of different abilities because yes
life is a dude in half with them that's
the stuff I'm curious to see how a
coalesce is oh yes movie and how they
kind of broaden out their physical like
their gadgets and stuff because like the
first one has a play on the gadgets of
you know the UK attire the London show
I'm getting at attire and now they're
doing it with the southern cowboy
retired yeah it looks like a really fun
time man I'm so amped for this video
yeah I can't wait I can't wait diseases
and enjoying more subs villain well she
is pretty oh looks pretty bad up I'm
excited to see her in a movie like this
play a role like that yeah I feel like
she can make a really bad as villain for
a movie like this
hell yeah it seems like a great way to
mix up the Kingsmen world and not just
be on repeat and Halle Berry Halle Berry
baby yeah all right guys what do you
think it Kings into the Golden Circle
red band trailer red band it wasn't like
that violent nice yeah yeah meaning this
video is unrestricted mode yeah but
whatever who hears so many other
trailers coming out over the week Comic
Con subscribe to the real rejects come a
part of the reject nation do it click
that notification bell he is dad John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and
please check out our exclusive perks and
rewards over at patreon.com slash the
real rejects would love to have you
become a part of that growing community
over there [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you